well joining me is Dylan posal who
played Hornswoggle the leprechaun in WWE
between 2006 and 2016 and by the
podcaster and commentator James Barr all
right uh James you've got a no problem
with what Disney are doing you think
this is Progressive and inclusive and
all those moaning about it should shut
up I think you should live in the 1930s
actually Pierce because that's where you
belong really listening to what you were
just saying then also I'm going to quote
Warwick Davis because he said he finds
it patronizing when people are offended
on his behalf and you've just spent a
five-minute monologue being offended on
his behalf and I think that's ridiculous
well let me bring in Dylan because Dylan
uh is also offended and he happens to be
a dwarf actor Dylan I've got to say I I
was very curious when I saw what Peter
Dinklage came out and said because I did
wonder who appointed him the head of the
dwarfactor community and it turns out
nobody other than him and the people who
it seems to me have really suffered and
all this are the six dwarf actors who
would have expected to have roles in
this remake in a massive Hollywood
Blockbuster who are now not going to
have that experience all the money all
the fame that may have come with that
what is your response to that
so it's not a progression at all to me
my issue with it is exactly what you
said there are actors dwarf actors that
live that dream to be in a major Motion
Picture such as this Disney remake and
now because Peter Dinklage said what he
said last year
now it's taken away and it's taken away
because of quote unquote progression and
all that that's it's not it's not really
it's not right because these are roles
made for actors of my stature roles that
aren't ever really given I can't go out
for the Harrison Ford or the George
Clooney roles because that's not for me
these dwarf roles are for people of my
stature right and now it's taken away
it I don't feel that's right and not
only that but now think about the
additional stunt actors or body doubles
or that now you're talking multiple
actors right of my stature that don't
get these major roles and why what's the
real what's the reasoning because we're
supposed to be Progressive and we're
supposed to just not view them as that
well you know the other heroes are these
dwarves all of the of these dwarves took
care of Snow White they all had
characteristics separate characteristics
they weren't these cave dwelling
monsters that that people speak of it's
It's they all had seven different
characteristics for seven different
actors that from my community and I
don't I don't feel it's right that they
got taken I completely and utterly agree
with you and the irony is that they
profess these progressives to want to do
this to protect you right they protect
dwarf actors from being you know somehow
smeared but you don't feel that way at
all Peter
Peter Dinklage spoke up about this and
that was my issue he had in the past no
issue cashing checks that were made for
dwarf rolls like elf and all of that yes
he blew away the barriers when he did
his his roles that weren't necessarily
made for a dwarf but
the elf roll was made for a dwarf that
check cleared just fine so now that he's
gone and done that the progression of
dwarf actors he's he it just doesn't it
doesn't sit right with me this guy who
is exactly what you said what what gave
him the voice for all of our community
let me bring Joe let me bring James back
here's Morgan is agreeing with you I
think you need to be concerned I'll say
that for the so you're telling the Dual
fact of what he should say hang on
having literally just lectured me about
speaking for someone in the dwarf
Community Warwick Davis you now accuse a
dwarf I'm not no it's not what I said I
said that if anyone if you're siding
with anyone you've got to worry what I'd
like to say actually is that I kind of
mostly agree with what you're saying now
you're it's
sir that's just taking a pot shot there
no saying oh yeah but I do agree with
what you're saying I completely agree
with your point of view and I think
that's really important but I I can only
speak from my experience and as a gay
man I know that growing up I witnessed
gay people being villains in movies when
I was seven dwarves art villains and
that I think stereotypes are really
important too what stereotypes in the
universe of Snow White wouldn't it be
good
this isn't a part of this about The
Stereotype right this is about roles
that were that were made for people such
of my stature that don't have the chance
to go out for other roles normally but
you James so why you you want to stop
Dylan
I'm not going to get into an attack you
don't want a dual factor I do a dwarf
part listen a dwarf can play a dwarf
part but I think it's important to
change narratives that don't fit in
today's society and really which is that
narrative it might be better
normal roles everywhere because they do
exist what was so bad about the way
dwarves are depicted in Snow White have
I missed something well that listen I'm
not that's right that's what I'm kind of
wondering is I don't represent Disney
but I'm just saying I think I see their
point of view what's their point of view
what was so bad about the depiction of
this why are you so upset about a movie
changing with the times and moving
forward because I think honestly there
is real news we could be discussing no
but this is real news if you're a dwarf
actor who are not out of work because of
virtue signaling idiots but you're just
using this everything has to be reread
you want you to be inclusive it's not
inclusive at all no you're using Dylan
as a cheap shot to attack a wokie that's
I don't think Dylan feels I'm using him
as a cheap shot and what I would say
about the wokey thing is this I have
spent the last year listening to people
tell me only gay actors should play gay
Parts only Welsh actress of Michael
Sheen should play Welsh characters and
so on and so on and so on but the moment
we have dwarf roles which are the most
famous dwarf roles in Hollywood history
then the only people apparently you
can't play them are dwarf actors and I
see there it's a cartoon King here it
has not changed it was a cartoon those
weren't actually dwarfs in the movie
they were drawn okay so firstly they
were drawn as dwarfs no that is
dwarves
they shouldn't be cool doors no they
should be called people what's wrong
with me
that's the story
apparently Dylan you're not allowed to
call yourself dwarves apparently
I would love to hear what should I call
myself sir I think you should call
yourself whatever you feel comfortable
with but as a person he calls himself
I'm happy so that so now but now sir let
me let me let me pause that
so we it shouldn't be called Snow White
and the Seven Dwarfs
because I think your point of view is
more important than mine right now but
what I'm annoyed about is peers trying
to take a cheap shot at someone that
believes in society moving forward yeah
I'm actually because really if I'm
actually exposing the hypocrisy of the
woke mentality of only gay people can
play gay Parts only trans actors can
play trans Parts until I think we took a
place
on the Seven Dwarves has to be canceled
because you're not allowed to have
dwarfs you should be happy peers because
it means that now you can play your
dream role of grumpy I would love to
play grumpy I loved all the dwarves in
that movie they were great being a
hypocrite you'd love to play crispy but
you're taking a wrong way from a dwarf
the issue at hand no I would play a
fully grown Grump quite happily taking
away a role from let me ask you Dylan
about the Hugh Grant playing an Oompa
Loompa because again it seems to me
we've got a clip of him playing a little
let's have a look at this
funny little man who's been following me
I will have you know that I am a
perfectly respectable size foreign
now they use CGI there Dylan to
effectively make him into an Oompa
Loompa so now what do you feel about
that yes sir so now
now we're not only
using CGI and spending extra money and
funding for these movies when we could
just cast dwarves in that role whether
it be one dwarf or multiple that like
they have been in the past now you're
taking at least one roll away or
multiple rolls away for Oompa Loompa
characters that that's what they were in
the past and and why again I go back to
my my stance on
these roles roles in Hollywood in
general are very hard for people of my
community to get besides the elf and the
leprechaun and this and that so why are
they being taken from my community
that's my issue here well you know what
you know stereotype you know why because
people like James here they think it's
Progressive and inclusive now when in
fact it's regressive it's regressive and
exclusive words Pierce I
Dylan Pierce I will I I will I will
agree with the mindset of it's not right
uh I don't know James James seems to be
in in partial agreeance with me on the
dwarf actors and the roles with that
that these should be but I I don't on
the other stuff I can't speak on that
obviously it's that's I'm focused fully
on the dwarf Community really losing
roles in these films I think James
starts with James strikes with all that
with all the writer strikes
I do agree with you and I think all I'm
trying to say is that I think it's a
nuanced conversation and there's a few
different points of view that are valid
and ultimately in my experience as a gay
man the reason we're upset about gay
people not getting gay roles in movies
is because we're not getting straight
roles as well and until we are it's
unfair that those roles are taken away
from us so with in that response what's
that got to do with more patches they
can't play regular size I think Peter
dinklish's original point is that he he
would like to see more dwarves in films
in general not just playing dwarfs in
Japanese literally I should a person of
my stature should be able to go out for
the same as a six foot five two hundred
pound human but it's it's just not that
way and I'm okay with that in reality
I'm okay with that it's understandable
to me but when it's these roles that are
made for people of myself yes that's
where I have the issue you know what
Dylan the movie one of the great movies
of all time is called Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs if if dwarf acts as in
Hollywood are not picked to play those
roles I don't know what roles you're
supposed to be playing it's it's
unbelievably I have patronizing they've
done this under the banner of so-called
progression
and it's not again like I said these
dwarves in that movie and or in this
this uh story aren't viewed poorly I
don't believe they're all separate
characters that are actually Heroes for
this lady yes and they take care and
they take this lady in they say you're
viewed so well to society they say it's
a woman now they're hard-working they're
wealthy they they are kind they are
generous hearted it's hard to think of a
more positive sort of goal narrative
about any people at all well let's just
go back to the 1930s peers I think you'd
be happy you know what James face would
exist no no no no it's not blackface
it's James it's not black face
oh you've lost the argument no there's
no argument you know you've been here
hold on hold on guys we agree with each
other please all right you know what you
do agree with him now because you
realize the futility of your argument
James you can't go and go oh you gotta
go back to 1930s no James when you if
you agree with what I'm saying I agree
with what you're saying I don't agree
with anything that peers yeah here's the
thing Dylan just to be clear he
literally just said well I said James
Dylan just to be clear he doesn't agree
when I say it but when you say it he
agrees that right now I'm not a dwarf no
but that right there is the hypocrisy of
the white Brigade uh Dylan okay okay so
let me let me just say dude I've got to
let go unfortunately quickly please
Pierce Pierce wrote James James let me
ask you this so if if a writer writes a
piece on what I'm saying is it wrong of
them because essentially that's the same
as the words coming out of my mouth what
yeah but you're not saying that I am
awoke Hypocrites and peers is and that's
what I disagree with because I'm
absolutely not I
he disagrees with what I say but when
you say exactly the same thing he
completely agrees with it I'm annoys
James Barr right to a tea nonsense
fantastic having you on Piers Morgan
uncensored you did such a brilliant job
in highlighting why this is so
ridiculous shame on Disney and I hope
you get another brilliant role very soon
I really do
well I I hope so too and I I hope that
uh this really kind of resounds with how
my how I feel yeah and I don't speak for
the whole dwarf culture and and
Community but this is
thank all of you thank you Jennifer
joining me uh James that's helpful thank
you for joining me because it's so well
you came on and you beautifully
highlighted the the PC hypocrisy culture
of your culture absolutely